Hi, I'm Dr. Cindy
Hoffman, and I am the
residency director at
St. Barnabas Hospital.
And I also have a couple
of offices, which are
in what you think is
upstate New York, but
it's actually Westchester
and Putnam Counties.
And the requirements of
this course, I'm going
to be actually giving
you three lectures.
The first is papula
squamous eruptions.
Then I'm going to
move on to pigmented
lesions. And then
the last lecture
is Skin Signs of
Systemic Disease.
And the requirements
of this course is the
handbook, the soft handbook,
Fitzpatrick's Color
Atlas and Synopsis of
Clinical Dermatology.
And the reason why
I chose this one is
because there are a
lot of pictures. And if
you're really interested
in dermatology,
there are a lot of
pictures in this book.
Now, a couple of years
ago, one of my students and
one of your colleagues asked,
she was very interested
in dermatology. And she
asked if she could put
together from these PowerPoint
lectures, a summary sheet
on my three lectures.
And I did send in those
summary sheets to your class.
So you should have them.
And it kind of just gives
a summary of the whole
lecture. And by the way, that
student is now a practicing
dermatologist. She became
one of my residents.
Okay, so this lecture
is papulosquamous
disorders. Now, what do
we mean by papulosquamous?
Papular meaning an
elevated papule,
squamous is scaly, and
erythematous. So all of these
conditions are in the
papulosquamous category. And why
do we have to know that?
Well, we have to know that
because when you're looking
at a rash, you want to be
able to determine that it is
either papulus squamous or
vesicular bullus or some
other pattern so that you're
able to then narrow down
the differential diagnosis.
And we're going to
be discussing the
differential diagnosis
in this category,
subreech dermatitis,
psoriasis,
peteriasis rosea,
lichen planus,
cutaneous T-cell lymphoma,
and fungal infections.
So we're going to be
reviewing all of these
today. And by the end of
the lecture, you should
be able to make a diagnosis
by putting it in this
papula squamous category,
and then also looking
at the patient's history,
the location of the
rash, things like that,
that we will be discussing
to better able to help
you make a diagnosis.
So the first case, this is
a 39 year old male. He had
a rash of the scalp and he
said it comes and goes for
many years. And he reported
that the rash sometimes
affects his face, especially
in the eyebrow area and
that no treatment has been
attempted. And he had no history
of any kind skin disease
or past medical history.
So here you see a patient
that has what you would think
is dandruff, correct? You
see these little, fine little
white scales. It's basically
dandruff. And the other
name for dandruff is suboreic
dermatitis. But suboreic
dermatitis does not only
really go into the scalp,
it can affect other areas
of the body, such as here.
Look at this scaly plaques
okay scaly plaques around the
eyebrows and then you have
the scaly erythematous
plaques around the nasolabial
folds now why is this important
to determine where these
plaques are because there's
another condition called
lupus and lupus you have a
butterfly rash and the
butterfly rash is basically
around the cheeks it affects
the dorsum of the nose right
there and it affects the
cheek over here. So it's
almost like in a butterfly
distribution where a suboreic
dermatitis is in the nasolabial
folds as you see here.
Suboreic dermatitis
can also affect
the chest as you see over here.
So again you have this
papula squamous category.
It's erythematous, it's
scaly, it's papular. Now
why did I put elbows and
knees are unaffected?
And why did I put that
nails are normal? Because in
this differential of
papula squamous eruptions,
you can also have
psoriasis. And
psoriasis does affect
the elbows and knees.
And psoriasis does
affect the nails.
So our differential
diagnosis includes psoriasis.
However, this patient does
not have any plaques on
the knees and the elbows,
does not have any nail
disease. So more likely
it's suboreic dermatitis.
What else is in the
differential? Atopic dermatitis,
peteriasis rosea, some
kind of fungal infection.
And we're going to go
over all of these so
that you're able to
differentiate all of these.
So how do you first
differentiate suboreic dermatitis
from psoriasis because
they're very similar in
the fact that they're
chronic conditions. However,
psoriasis, you also have
arthritis and joint pain.
Sobretic dermatitis
can be itchy,
whereas psoriasis
usually not so itchy.
Sobretic dermatitis, you
see these greasy, yellow,
white, scaly plaques,
But with psoriasis,
the plaques are
much thicker, and
there are nail
findings in some cases.
And seborrheic
dermatitis, that affects
the scalp, as you
saw, the nasolabial
folds, the eyebrows,
and the chest.
In psoriasis, it
typically affects the
extensor areas, such
as the scalp, elbows,
and knees, and it
rarely affects the face.
so what is the workup for
seborrheic dermatitis well
this is a chronic condition
it affects a lot of people
healthy people however
if you have an acute new
onset of seborrheic dermatitis
and it's severe you always
want to think about hiv and
you would do hiv testing
in those patients how do
you treat this condition
well i'm sure you've gone
to cvs you've seen sell some
blue shampoo, head and
shoulders. These treatments,
selenium sulfide or
zinc pyrithione shampoo,
these treatments are used to
treat seborrheic dermatitis.
They can actually also
treat psoriasis as well.
And we would use a topical
steroid for the scalp
and then a low potency
steroid for the face
because you don't want
to use something that's
so strong on the face
that you would use on the
scalp. The next case, this
is a 24-year-old female.
She presents with the rash
on her stomach and back and
she states that the rash
started with one spot. Now
this one spot is a clue and
so she starts with this one
spot on her stomach and
then a couple of weeks later
she noticed more spots
appearing and they're not
really that itchy but it kind
of comes all of a sudden.
She did note that she
had an upper respiratory
infection, but no other
past medical history.
So here you see this
one spot that happens
first, and this is
called a herald patch.
Now, a herald patch starts
first. A couple of weeks
later, you get this more
generalized eruption.
The lesions are oval scaly
papules. And you'll see
in another picture where
it's in a Christmas tree
distribution, Christmas tree
distribution on the back.
And that's how it
looks. And that's how
sometimes you can
differentiate this condition
from something called
gut tate psoriasis.
Also, gut tate psoriasis
doesn't have this one
patch that starts first
called the herald patch.
So what's your differential
here? tinea corporis or
fungal infection, tinea
versicolor or yeast infection,
guttate psoriasis,
peteriasis rosea, a drug
eruption, but the patient
didn't complain that they
were on any medications
that could have caused
this, and secondary
********. Now, just to
note, guttate psoriasis,
peteriasis rosea, and secondary
********, they all look
very similar. So we really
do have to differentiate
the three of these, and
I will show you how.
So what tests can
we order to narrow
down the differential
diagnosis?
Tinea corporis, we do a
KOH prep, right? We do,
we take a little scraping
of the skin, we put
that scraping on a slide,
we do a KOH prep, and
we see branching hyphae,
as you can see here.
How do we know it's
not tinea versicolor?
Well, we do a KOH prep again.
We take a little bit of
the skin, we put the skin
on the slide, we do a KOH
prep, and you see what's
called spaghetti and
meatballs. The spaghetti
is the hyphae, and the
meatballs are the spores.
Secondary ********,
how do we know it's
not that? Well, we
do a VDRL, which is a
blood test, and it
doesn't show ********.
And then the last is
pitoriasis rosia and guttate
psoriasis. And we do an
antistreptolysin antibody titer
to see if the patient has a
preceding strep infection.
And if they do, it can
make you more lead to the
diagnosis of either
pitoriasis rosia or guttate
psoriasis. But then you
have to determine which of
these it is. Pitoriasis
rosea really only lasts
for about eight weeks. Gut
tape psoriasis can last
much longer. So that's
how you can also make that
determination. History
is very, very important.
So pitoriasis rosea, it's
an acute erythematous
eruption, usually most commonly
occurs in the spring and
fall. It does, it can, it
doesn't always have to have
a preceding upper respiratory
infection. And the clue,
it has this herald patch
in 80% of the patients.
And that's that single plaque
that develops usually on
the trunk. And then a few
days later to a few weeks
later, you can get this
generalized eruption with
scaling papules and plaques in
a Christmas tree distribution.
I told you that before.
And it's confined to
the trunk and proximal
extremities, it's more common
on the upper arms, on the
upper thighs, and in the
trunk. And it does occur
along the skin lines. And it
usually resolves in maybe
6 to 12 weeks, and usually
it does not recur, and we
treat this symptomatically.
The next case, this is a 15
-year-old male. He develops
a generalized rash that
started after an episode
of a strep infection. Now,
wait, this could be pterosis
rosia. So how do you know
it's not pterosis rosia?
Well, the patient has these
generalized salmon pink
papules, and it's more in
a generalized distribution.
It's not only on the trunk
and upper extremities. It
can be all over the body.
It can look a little bit
like psoriasis, and look
here, look at this elbow. The
patient has an erythematous
scaly plaque, which is
common for psoriasis, but
it also has the morphology
of teardrops. That's what
they call these teardrops.
So we want to rule
out peteriasis rosia.
We want to rule out
a drug eruption, but
the patient hasn't
been on any medication.
We want to rule out secondary
********. We want to
rule out tinea corporis,
which is a fungal infection,
and you do that KOH
prep to do that, and you
want to rule out guttate
psoriasis. So all these are
in the differential of
papulus squamous disorders.
So this is a case of
eruptive guttate psoriasis.
You have these
generalized scaly pink
papules, They look
like teardrops. And the
differential, as we
mentioned before,
drug, secondary
********, PR, tinea.
And you differentiate
all of these
by the ways that we
discussed before.
You can get an ASO titer
and see if the patient has
a preceding strep infection.
You can get a VDRL to
see if the patient has
********. And you can do a KOH
prep to see if the patient
has a tinea infection.
so differentiating between
pteriasis rosea and
guttate psoriasis history
very important but they both
can have a preceding upper
respiratory infection
or a strep throat pr is
confined to the strong and
proximal extremities
guttate psoriasis is more
generalized it could be
more concentrated over the
knees and elbows and pr has
this herald patch whereas
guttate psoriasis has
this teardrop appearance.
Here you see this more
Christmas tree type of
pattern on the back in
peteriasis rosea, and here
you see the guttate
psoriasis, more generalized,
discreet teardrop
-like papules. Here the
papules are more oval,
erythematous, and scaly.
The next case is a 22-year
-old male. He has a rash on
his trunk for three weeks
since the beginning of the
summer, and he reports that
the rash mostly is present
in the summers, but
kind of goes away in the
winter. So what do you have
to think about when a patient
comes in like that? You
always think that the patient
has this rash in maybe a
hot, moist environment.
So what can cause a rash in
a hot, moist environment?
Here you see this hyperpigmented
patch. It's kind of
very well, it's kind of
diffuse all over the trunk.
And here you see it
again, hyperpigmented
patches and macules. macules.
So the differential
is tinea versicolor,
peteriasis rosea,
secondary ********, drug
eruption, patients not
on any medication, psoriasis.
And you kind of have
ruled these three out
because you did a KOH
prep and you see yeast
under the microscope. soap.
So what is tinea versicolor?
It's sharply marginated
hyper, which is darker than
normal skin, hypo, which is
lighter than normal skin,
macules and papules of
varying size. And it's most
common on the upper trunk,
the arms, the stomach,
the axilla, in areas where
you sweat more and it's more
common in the summer in a
hot moist environment. You
do a KOH and what do you see?
You see the spaghetti and
meatballs or the hyphae
and the spores. And the way
to treat this is anti-ease
medication or you can use
selenium sulfide shampoo.
And that's what I usually do
with my patients. I give
them an antifungal anti-ease
medication and I tell them
to get sell some blue over
the counter and they actually
it's a shampoo but they
leave it on their body for
10-15 minutes and wash it off
so here you see these
hypopigmented areas on the skin
and here you see hypopigmented
patches on the skin
the next case this is a 27
year old female she developed
a rash on her scalp
elbows and knees. And this
is a clue. The rash has a
thick white scale. And the
other clue is that it's on
the elbows and knees. And
this is the extensor areas
of the body. And so this
indicates more of a psoriasis
than either a pterosis
rosea or subreech dermatitis.
Now, another clue, You
take that thick white scale,
the erythematous plaque
with the thick white scale,
and you attempt to lift
it up and remove it. And
underneath, the lesion tends
to bleed. And this is
called the ospit sign. So
that's a clue that this
patient has a psoriasis lesion.
Also, her grandmother
had a similar
rash. So you know
it can be genetic.
And the grandmother also
had severe arthritis.
So that is something that
psoriasis patients can
have. They can have
arthritis and joint pain.
So here you see
these thick scaly
plaques here around the elbows.
Here, thick scaly erythematous
plaques around the knees.
So your differential is
the same differential
of all the other papulose
squamous diseases.
Psoriasis, tinea,
secondary ********, contact
dermatitis, atopic dermatitis.
So what makes you think that
the patient has psoriasis?
What are some hints that
this patient has psoriasis?
The thick silvery white
scale, that's number one.
It affects the extensive
surface of the body,
such as the elbows and
knees and the scalp.
There's a family
history of psoriasis,
and the patient has joint pain.
So what are some other
hints that we use to
indicate that the patient
may have psoriasis? Well,
the first thing is called
the Kebner phenomenon.
Now, if somebody injures
themselves, they have
trauma to an area,
they have surgery in an
area, they have some
kind of injury to the
area, they can develop
new psoriasis lesions.
And this is called
the Kebner phenomenon.
And what are some triggers?
Well, some cuts and
abrasions, right? You
fall, you hurt yourself,
you're going to get psoriasis.
You can get psoriasis
in that area if you
have a predisposition to
psoriasis. Tattoo needles,
you can get psoriasis.
Patient has some itching
in an area, they're
chronically scratching
and rubbing the
skin, they can get
psoriasis in that area.
Patient has an allergy
to something, they touch
bacitracin and they're
allergic to bacitracin and they
get a little rash and then
they can get psoriasis
in that area. And chemical
burns. So all of these can
cause psoriasis lesions,
new psoriasis lesions in
patients that already have
a history of psoriasis.
So here you see psoriasis
lesion in a tattoo.
Here you see psoriasis
lesions in a patient who
had shingles. They had
the shingles rash, which
is a blistering rash, and
then afterwards they get
psoriasis. And then
here you have a surgical
incision. Patient develops
psoriasis in that area.
So other hints, we went
over the auspid sign. These
are bleeding points
representing capillaries in the
papillary dermis, and the
papillary dermis is the
upper part of the skin and
here you see you lift up
the plaque and under the
plaque you see these little
bleeding points that is
called the auspice sign.
Nail findings is another
hint for psoriasis.
Onycholysis now if you
look at your nail your nail
is usually pink right but
in this onycholysis you
can have a lifting of the
nail from the nail bed and
it causes this white
discoloration of the nail.
You can also have pitting.
There are little pits in
the nails. That can be an
indication of psoriasis.
And you also can have this
called an oil spot. Now
this is pathognomonic
for psoriasis. And the
reason why I say it's
pathognomonic is because if you
have this spot, you most
likely have psoriasis.
The next case is a 54
-year-old Caucasian male.
He presents with an
asymptomatic rash of
the trunk that comes
and goes for years. He
tried several prescription
creams. They help
temporarily, but the
rash keeps on returning.
And this patient was diagnosed
with either eczema or
psoriasis over many years.
And, you know, the creams
help a little bit, but
it doesn't kind of really
go away and come back. It
just doesn't do anything.
So here you have
this bizarre plaque.
See this rash? Kind of
bizarre looking, right?
They are scaly
patches and plaques
with an irregular
configuration.
Your differential
is the same, and
this patient has
mycoses fungoides.
And what is mycoses fungoides?
It's actually the most
common cutaneous lymphoma.
It's lymphoma of the
skin. and it's a proliferation
of T-cells and there
are different stages and
the stages include the patch
stage which looks like
a little patch of eczema
psoriasis, the plaque
stage which is a little bit
thicker than that and then
the tumor stage which is even
thicker than that and
the prognosis is actually
related to the stage. So
usually when a patient is
misdiagnosed with eczema
psoriasis Usually it's in the
patch or plaque stage,
but by the time you get to
the tumor stage, you've
done a biopsy at that point.
And then you treat it
symptomatically. So if it's the
patch and plaque stage, you
do treat it with topical
steroids. But if it's the
tumor stage, then there
are more aggressive treatments
that we have to use.
So as I said, the patient
for months or years
had either psoriasis
or a numular eczema,
or some other similar
condition and the skin lesions
as i said are patches plaques
or tumors but patients
may have simultaneously
they may have at the
same time patches plaques
and tumors at the same time
this is the patch stage
and at first superficial
it looks like eczema or
psoriasis and that's why the
patient is just treated
by the doctor with some
topical steroids and this
can mimic dermatophytosis
or a fungal infection and
that's why it's called
mycosis fungoides and later
these patches can become
thicker and become plaques
and plaques have a pretty
bizarre configuration
but they are thicker than
the patches and then you
have the tumor stage which
are later lesions consisting
of nodules and tumors.
Here you might see the
patch stage, right?
It's kind of thin.
Here you might see the
plaque stage. And then
here you might see the
tumor stage. And then
by the time it gets to
this stage, it's almost
like an ulceration.
So here, what's the diagnosis?
We call this the five Ps.
it's purple right it has a
little bit of a violaceous
or purplish look to it
it's polygonal meaning
it has it's multi-sided
it's peridic or itchy
it's planar or flat
and it's a papule or a
plaque so this is the
five p's of lichen planus
and where else should you
suspect that the patient
may have lichen planus
if you see it on the
skin and usually it's on
the ankles and wrists but
if you see it on the
ankles and wrists you also
have to look in the mouth
and it looks different
in the mouth it has this
lacy-like appearance
in the mouth and what is
this called wickamstria
so what should we ask
about in the patient's
medical history and do
you want to order any
tests? Well, if the patient
has lichen planus and
we biopsy it and it's
proven to be lichen
planus, we always want to
order a hepatitis C test
because hepatitis C can
cause lichen planus.
The next case, this is a
30-year-old female with
two pet dogs at home and
she develops a rash. Now
what does this rash look
like? It's an erythematous,
annular, scaly plaque,
right? And what's in the
center? Kind of has some
central clearing to it. So
the rash is red and
scaly, the lesions are
erythematous, annular, and
it has some central clearing.
So same differential as all the
other papulus
squamous eruptions.
However, when you scrape
the edge of this, and
you put the scale on
the slide, you can see
hyphae. So that's, you do
a KOH prep, you see hyphae,
you're making a diagnosis
of tinea corporis.
So what is the most common
cause of tinea corporis?
Trichophyton rubrum is
the most common cause.
And it's a dermatophyte
infection caused by
either auto-inoculation.
In other words, you
have the rash in one
area and then you get it
in a different area
or animal contact. And
they're annular plaques
with central clearing.
What is tinea
incognito? Now look
at this rash. It's
annular, right?
It's kind of like ring
-like around here. You do
have some areas of
central clearing, but what
happened is that the
doctor gave this patient a
topical steroid and a very
strong topical steroid,
thinking that the patient
had eczema. And so
what happens is the
patient looks like they're
clearing, but in reality
it's going to get worse.
So tinea incognito is the
presentation of dermatophytosis
or a fungal infection
after the application of
topical steroids. This
patient really need to have a
scraping at the edge, do a
KOH prep, see that it's a
******, and treat them with
an antifungal medication.
Onychomycosis is
****** of the nails.
The distal, see this is the
distal part of the nail.
This is a cause, this
is called onychomycosis,
a superficial white.
This looks like a white
part of the nail causing
onychomycosis, and the
proximal part of the
nail over here can cause
onychomycosis, can be
onychomycosis. And what can
cause these? Well, here,
the distal part can be
caused by trichophyton
rubrum. The superficial
white can be caused by
trichophyton mentagraphides,
and then the proximal
can be caused by also
trichophyton rubrum,
more associated with HIV.
the next case is a patient
that presents with a
rash in the inguinal area
and what's your differential
diagnosis okay so here
you see this annular
plaque right maybe a
little bit clear in here it
could be tineacurus what
is tineacurus it's a fungal
infection in the groin
area but But you always
have to differentiate
tinea croris with eczema,
candida, inverse
psoriasis, other
conditions that can
also occur in this area.
So we might call this
intertrigo. And what
intertrigo is, is a
diagnosis of exclusion.
In other words, the patient
may have candida, the
patient may have tinea, the
patient may have psoriasis.
You're not really, really
sure. So you call this
intertrigo. And what
that is, is a rash in the
intitrigenous areas. And what
are the intitrigenous areas?
Areas under the armpits,
under the breasts, in
the groin, areas where the
skin folds come together.
This patient can also have
inverse psoriasis, but
inverse psoriasis is usually
much redder than this.
The patient can have candida,
but usually there are
little satellite pustules
at the edge of this rash.
The patient can
have erythrasma, but
erythrasma is a
little bit more brown
and this is a
little bit more red.
And the patient can have
eczema. So all of this is
in the differential
diagnosis of this case. And
we're going to determine
which this is because in the
next few slides that will
help you determine that.
So how can we
distinguish the etiology?
So first, intertrigo. This
occurs in places where,
as I said, opposing
skin surfaces come, such
as the armpits under the
breast and the groin.
There are erythematous
patches or plaques
that oppose each other
on either side of the
skin fold. It has a
mirror image of each other
and it's a diagnosis
of exclusion because
you want to rule out
all these other things.
So here you see the
skin folds and here the
erythematous rashes on both
sides of the skin folds.
Next is ternia cruris. I'm
sure most of you have heard
of jock itch. This is a
rash on the inner thighs and
groin. It's caused by
trichophyton rubrum and you get
these annular plaques with
central clearing. Now a clue
is that first of all you're
going to do a KOH exam for
fungal culture but tinea
cruris does not affect the
******* and the ***** area.
It kind of just affects the
inner thighs and so that's
how you differentiate it
from candida and eczema because
as Candida and eczema and
psoriasis can affect the
******* and the ***** area.
So here you see tinea
cruris, annular scaly
plaques, as you see
here with some central
clearing, and it does
not affect the *******.
Now inverse psoriasis,
so I told you that
psoriasis is on the
extensor areas of the body,
including the elbows
and the knees. However,
inverse psoriasis
is localized to the
intertriginous areas,
under the armpits, under
the breasts, and the
groin. And it's not
that common, but
patients can get this.
And what this is, you
have that deep red color
that you would normally
get on the elbows and
knees, but here you get
it in the groin area,
whereas the tinea cruris
is not as deep red.
And this condition often
affects the ***** and *******.
And you would also probably
see psoriasis elsewhere
on the body, like the
elbows and knees. And you
do a KOH prep, and it's
negative in this condition.
So here you see this very, very
erythematous, beefy red plaque.
Well, if you didn't see this
over here, you can think
that this is tinea cruris.
But this is much redder
than tinea cruris. And look,
it affects the *******.
Candidiasis, this is an
infection with candida,
and it's very common
in elderly patients,
diabetic patients, and
immunocompromised patients,
because it also occurs in
a hot, moist environment,
and it's beefy red,
just like psoriasis is
beefy red, but the difference
is you can see these
satellite pustules at the
border, extending beyond
the border of the
rash, and then you do a
scraping. You take a little
bit of the scan. You put
the scan on a slide. You
do a KOH prep and you see
yeast. And that's how
you know this is candida.
So here you see the rash
and here you see these
little satellite pustules
outside the rash.
Erythrasma, this is a
bacterial infection. It's also
caused by excessive sweating.
patients who are obese
patients who are diabetic
patients who are immunocompromised
and in a hot moist
environment the way to
make this diagnosis is you
shine a woods light a woods
light is ultraviolet a light
and what happens is you
get a coral red fluorescence
of this rash caused by
the porphyrins produced by
the bacteria of the rash.
So here you see the
ultraviolet light in this area,
erythrasma.
Eczema can also occur in
this groin area. If you
have an itch down there,
you're repetitively rubbing
and scratching, if you
have maybe a little
eczema in the groin area,
you can get what's called
lichen simplex chronicus.
And this is from repetitive
rubbing and scratching.
And it occurs mainly
in patients that have a
history of eczema, but you
get these thickened
lichenified plaques in that
area. You do a KOH and
it's negative. So you know
it's not tinea cruris.
You know it's not candida.
so here you see
this erythematous
plaque of lichen
simplex chronicus
this case this is a 67 year
old african-american female
she develops a red oozing
lesion on the inner aspect
of her right ankle and she
also complains that her
lower legs are swollen now
she does have a history of
hypertension and DVT or
deep vein thrombosis. She
has bilateral leg edema and
she has this ulcer in the
center here and the
hyperpigmentation on the outside.
So this is a case of stasis
dermatitis and what that
is is an inflammatory dermatitis
of the lower extremities.
And it's most common in
patients with chronic
renal insufficiency where
age plays a part. If you're
older, you're more likely
to have circulation issues.
If you're standing all
the time, if you're obese,
if you have a history of
DVT or deepening thrombosis,
congestive heart failure,
hypertension. So stasis
dermatitis is a late
manifestation of chronic venous
insufficiency. And you see
here, you have this red rash
first. Later on, it becomes
scaly and little crusty,
and it's more susceptible to
a bacterial infection. And
then the last stage is
this hyperpigmentation with
ulcers in the center. It's
associated with varicose
veins, and so it happens is
chronic venous insufficiency
causes edema of the legs
and then that edema of the
legs or swelling can cause
hyperpigmentation, eczema,
fibrosis or stiffening
of the skin,
atrophy and ulceration.
So here again you see
the early signs which is
just this erythema of the
ankle, moving on to the
scaling, crusting of the
leg, more susceptible
to a bacterial infection,
and then you have the
advanced stage where you
have hyperpigmentation,
stiffening of the
skin, and ulceration.
That concludes this lecture.